Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights At Freddy's VR: Help Wanted
There are only Night Terrors left in the main portion of the game.
I'm not talking about the butthole dimension that is this version of the game
No, that's something completely different
I don't even know what this is about,
And I don't think I wanna know what this is about
so I'm not gonna pretend like I know what this is about
and I'm gonna, I'm just gonna - *click*
we're just gonna move on out of there and pretend that's not actually a thing
because it doesn't have to be a thing until it's actually a thing.
*iNHALE*
But for right now,
We're gonna go into Night Terrors.
And..
That looks like Five Nights at Freddy's 4 but it's not saying it's Five Nights at Freddy's 4
which leads me to believe that it's
something different.
I don't know what exactly, but I know I'm gonna hate it!
Oh, I hate it!
*laughs*
I hate it already!
"Close doors and grab and release with trigger."
Uh,
Nope!
Ah, "Flashlight: press and hold stick." Nope!
"Teleport: point and pull trigger."
That-
I- I feel like I'll mess that up.
"Survive til" - ughHHGHH
If you say so, that sounds totally fair.
Let's- whatever let's just go and die.
*sigh*
Oh heyywoah -
What the hell?? Woah
Oh
OH!
OH!!!
[childish giggle]
Wh-
waaaaAAAAY
[footsteps]
Ho
Am I listening?
Oh god
am I listening?
Hi!
Hello!
Do I-
aAhHhH
Oh gohd!
[footsteps]
THIS IS THE WORST
Oh
[Funtime Freddy laugh]
AHHHHHH
Funtime Freddy: Well, hello again!
Oh hi
Hello how are you?
[footsteps]
Good to see you
I dunno what I'm doin'
I dunno how I'm doin' it
I dunno what they expect me to do?
I-
[screaming]
WHAOHH! OH FUCK!! HA-
Oh
Uh
uh
Uh oh- okay
Is- is that all?
[footsteps]
Whadoido
Wait I don't wanna go to the doors I wanna go to the middle!
HOW DO I GO TO THE MIDDLE?!
HOW DO I GO TO THE MIDDLE-
GO BACK ON THE BEEEEEED!! D:
Oh god okay
Oh hi o.o
Uh
Wh-
No thanks!
Ju-Just no thanks-Woah! What the hell?!
You still there?
You s- You still there?
You st-You still there? Okay you're still there.
I'm gonna have to two-hand this
I don't- WHAT DO I DO...!
ABOUT YOU?!
I don't know, I-I
(Random gibberish)
There's no way to go back- hi- okay yeah okay sure.
There's no way to go back.
It's impossible to go back
Once I've gone forward, I can never go BACK!
Okay, I'll just stare at you for a looong time
Hey, buuuddy...
You are a fun... friend...
Fun
times,
[giggle]
With friends!
Friendly fun times!
I don't even think I even can leave, can I?
It's- It's not letting me move anywhere
I'm stuck here- SO
It's just YOU AND ME!
FOR A LITTLE BIT!
So all I can do with my time here is judge you
I think your color combination is deplorable!
Which means BAD! In case your brain was too small to understand what deplorable meant.
Which judging by that blank, deer-like expression on your face, IS ACCURATE!
So YOU'RE stupid and I'm smart,
If you want--AAAAGGHH FUCKING
G O O D B Y E
YOU- I'm not done with you.
I'll judge y- whoever you were- later
I'm judgin' you right now.
So listen to me, and listen good
Oh, you're STUNNED there, you can't believe I'm revealing the TROOFS of your own existense
To your own FACE!
You SUCK!
Your little pink mustache is just a ripoff of Warfstache!
I know you're just a fanboy...
Or
WHATEVER YOU ARE!
I know you're just a fan and that's all you'll ever be.
Just a FAN!
Fun time fan boy--
AGGH FUCK OFF!
FREDDY!
*sigh*
So...
I hope you take this as a lesson learned
That you suck and I'm awesome, so don't even THINK.
Don't even THINK about coming back here
EVER...
Ever...
EVER AGAIN!!!
EVER NEVER NEVER
Alright?
Good, glad we got that cleared up. Thank you. What time is it--
[Bell tolls]
YEAAAH
Yeah, that's what I thought!
Yeah I beat that right!
Yeah I beat this game good.
[kids cheering]
There's no... timer What?
Pardon me? I'm in the void.
[smol jumpscare]
Oh- (laughing).
I win!
I guess... (In weird voice) what the hell?
I ha-
I don't know how to-
Ohoho- heeey.
Mark: Didn't I already beat you up?
Bonnie plush: oH yOu DiD
bUt YoU cOuLd AlWaYs TrY aGaIn, SuCkeR.
Mark: Oh. I don't need to be a sucker to beat you up.
Ha-BOINK x2
Mark: Wait, my punches!
Bonnie plush: YeAh ThAt'S rIgHt, bItCh
Bonnie plush: ThEy Do NoThInG
Mark: They do NOTHING?!
Bonnie plush: ThAt'S wHat I sAiD
Mark: But that's what I said!
Bonnie plush: i'M in YoUr MiiiiiiiiiiiD
Mark: OH GOD I THINK YOU'RE IN MY MIND!
Bonnie plush: CaN yOu NoT hEar Me?
Mark: (confused Markimoo noises.)
Okay, whatever.
the fair- fair I played tha-
Oh god! Uhh… "Nightmarionne"?
Nightmarionne?... is that the name?
Okay all right, "Nightmarionne" I don't know...
I still don't know how to beat this (nervous chuckle)
Ahh, I beat the other one just by a fluke so umm...
(high pitched Mario voice) Weee here we go!
(exasperated sigh)
That's open now which... ain't good
I know that for certainty
Ummm....
right... uhh...
(music box playing)
Hoo!
(music box starts playing)
wha- wha
What do I do? What do I do about that!?
Do I go in! How do I go in?!
What do I do?
[footsteps]
Oh-Oh shit, Oh fuck, oh fuck me
Oh fuck me, oh how do get back to the-
How do I get back to the MIDDLE!?
[footsteps]
Oh fuck me-
AHH- AHH WOAHx4
Nightmarionne: 𝙄 𝙖𝙢 𝙩𝙝𝙚 𝙛𝙚𝙖𝙧𝙛𝙪𝙡 𝙧𝙚𝙛𝙡𝙚𝙘𝙩𝙞𝙤𝙣-𝙚𝙘𝙩𝙞𝙤𝙣... (𝙜𝙧𝙪𝙢𝙗𝙡𝙚)
...𝙮𝙤𝙪 𝙝𝙖𝙫𝙚 𝙘𝙧𝙚𝙖𝙩𝙚𝙙.
[slithery tentacle noises]
Mark: Oh fuc-
OHH FUCK!
[slithery tentacle noises]
WOOH MY GOD!
OOH MY GOD
WHAT IS THAT??
AHHHH
what da fu, what the ohohohoh
ooh oohh ohh ohh
oh
ohh my god
oh my god, oh my god
oh my god - what am I doing?
what am I doing, what am I doing, what am I doing
you're still trying to - wha what what do I do, what do I do
what do I do, oh my god...
what the fuck
I goOOAAHH--
Nightmarionne: 𝙄 𝙖𝙢 𝙩𝙝𝙚 𝙛𝙚𝙖𝙧𝙛𝙪𝙡 𝙧𝙚𝙛𝙡𝙚𝙘𝙩𝙞𝙤𝙣-𝙚𝙘𝙩𝙞𝙤𝙣... (𝙜𝙧𝙪𝙢𝙗𝙡𝙚)
...𝙮𝙤𝙪 𝙝𝙖𝙫𝙚 𝙘𝙧𝙚𝙖𝙩𝙚𝙙.
Mark: I didn't cReAtE ANYTHING COME ON!
You still there?
Oh god, I can't see I'm closing it!
Oh oh my god
Oh why is it so... tentacle-like??
Uggh
why is it so- I CAN'T SEE DOWN THERE
*sighs* fuck...
Okay I don't know what that is all about
I- I haven't got the foggiest what that's all about...
and I don't know what i'm supposed to- *music stops*
AHHHH WHHHA
*static*
*befuddled* What do I do??
What. Do. I. Do???
[Freddy laughter]
WhAt Do I dO?!?
WHAT
DO I
DO??!?!?
WHAT DO I DO??
WHAT DO I DO???
Well i'm just asking as clear as I can ask,
W H A T   D O   I   D O  ?
What do I do
I don't know what I do
I don't know why any of this,
I can't go, I can't get the closet
[music box plays]
...Oh fuck me
I don't know what...
*groans in frusterasion* x4
i'm gonna bite the big one here,
'bout to bite some big ones!
big ones are about to be bit!
You know what i'm just gonna leave it plugged
ooOOOAAHH FUCK okay so
there-
whatever it is flashlight, weird-- aokay
whatever it is,
[Freddy laughter]
ugghhh
(Inaudible Markimoo sounds and music box)
[slithery tentacle noises]
Oh fuck
Go- oh my god
[footsteps]
What the fuck that noise?
Okay yer not there
but I hear the goopyness
God wat the fuck?
What the fuck
the fuck...
what the fuck, what the fuck I can't see-?
Ookay therewego...
Goopyness okay goopyness, WHY IS THERE GOOPYNESS
I don't get the goopyness
AH FUCK GOD
FUCK
*deep breathing*
This one doesn't make a lot of sense to me
Poofgh
But I'll figure it out!
I will figure this out!
What do I do? I don't- *music box*
Do I wait? WOAH! x1
WOAH x2
WOAH x3
Ho fuck the eyes!
Okay the eyes! Got it understood
Duly noted
Kay so I gotta make him go all the way away
And then what? Do I go over there now?
uH
Don't see nothin' there
Okay go away go away
go awaygoawaygoaway
goawaygoawaygoaway
All the way away, okay.
Kay alright so the eyes
The eyes are the thing look for the eyes
There's some eyes! close the door
annd... look at the tentacles...
that seems like a logical thing to definitely do...
in my spare time...
In my experience,
best... thing I've ever done
Is look at tentacles,
And eyes
Always good moves in my book...
U still there?
YEH YOU ARE O MY GOD
okay anyone there?
come on,
Go away goawaygoway...
All the way away, all the way away!
All the way-- All the way away!
Okay over there, what about over here?
Okay...
any eyes? No
K Go away go away
go away, go away
God, you suck!
Just go away! All the way away, okay you still there?
I bet! I bet! I betIbetIbet
K here we go yeah yeah okay
I- uh this doesn't make the most sense in the world
but...
But im fine with it
nah na na, naa na na
Go away go away
You over there? Oh fuck yer over here aren't ya
Na yer not over here, okay where are ya?
GO AWAY GO AWAY GO AWAY
awayawayaway
awaylayawaylayaway
Yer getting- AH FUCK GAAAAD
DAMMIT
FUUUCK
*sigh* I was very close I was close
[Freddy laughter]
It was 5:00am
I just *sigh*
Kay not there, kay not there
Go away go away go away
Goin' over?
YEPYEPYEPYEP YEPERSPEPPERS
YEPPERSPEPPERS YEPPERSPAPPINOS
OOOOH YEPPERSPEPPERS OKAY
Cum on cum on cum on eggo
Okay you here?
[bells toll]
HA!!!
*deep inhale*
*exhale*
[kids cheering]
*sigh*
Don't scare me before I...
Okay good!
hAaH
Frick!
Frack!
Fruck!
[music box]
Guh!! That was just panicking!
[kids cheering]
"Sodaroni"??
"Innovation in carbonation"?
Wow! [cRONCH]
Alrigh--- I don't know why I ate the whole can...
The crunch was not reassuring...
Aokay here we go
Circus Baby, you're not gonna beat me!
Now that I know generally the recipe,
...
They're gonna change the frickin recipe aren't they?
Oh! "Grab and release…"
Oh, "Close the doors" that's all I gotta do?
Oh well then this'll-- this'll be easy!
All I gotta do is close the doors!
Whoa! Fucking...
screw you- oh I'll take that, thank you
Baby: 𝘐𝘵 𝘧𝘦𝘦𝘭𝘴 𝘭𝘪𝘬𝘦…
Mark: oH shit!
Baby: 𝘮𝘺 𝘣𝘪𝘳𝘵𝘩𝘥𝘢𝘺...
M: IT'S NOT YOUR BIRTHDAY!
Baby: 𝘥𝘪𝘥 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘩𝘢𝘷𝘦 𝘢 𝘨𝘪𝘧𝘵 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘮𝘦?
M: nOOOOO
Wah!
[garbled speech rising intensity]
WAH!!! AAAAAH!!!
AHHHHH WHAAATTHEFUCK ?!?!
WHADID I DO?!?!
Did I leave the doors closed forever?
[Freddy laughter]
"Remember Jeremy"
*high pitched* I DON'T WANT to remember Jeremy thank you!
I've got a tape to remember Jeremy, but that doesn't mean I have to remember Jeremy
I don't know who Jeremy is and I don't care who Jeremy is... to be frank...
*sigh* Fine, I'll go listen to the goddamn tape.
Yeah okay...
Yeah yeah yeah,
The tape, the tape,
the tape, the tape
the tape, the tape, the tape... the fucking tape...
Uh huh, uh huh...
uh huh...
Uh huh okay...
Right.
Uh huh
Riiight...
Okay, Jeremy, sure...
I don't know who Jeremy is,
but he obviously has done bad if he went against the company's wishes
Hi there
Ahh... How are you doing good?
Good great good
great good great
I'm gonna go back in here, um,
So maybe I panicked I think what it was is that I closed the doors for too long,
the shaky babies didn't like that,
and if you- if they get too shaky they no happy,
I get it I get it I understand.
I'm the same way.
ooh hi, um...
peekaboo
uh whOOA
OH
Baby: 𝘐 𝘩𝘦𝘢𝘳𝘥 𝘺𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘤𝘢𝘭𝘭…
M: Ooh!
M: Uh oh, that's not good!
A h
H I
[screaming]
OH FUCK HI HELLOOOHOHO!
[static]
OH!
OH, OKAY!
[Freddy laughter]
D...uh, then what am I-
Phuh!
bRrR
brHRHR
BRHRHR
BRUH!
BRUHHH
BRUUUUUUHHH
Okay so maybe I just gotta let her see me...
so that I can- ooh! Uhh, that's weird...
Hi
Baby: 𝘵𝘸𝘰... 𝘰𝘯𝘦...
M: OH, look, you don't need to-- nope--
Hello?
oOOH WAH- AHHHH
Oh fuck, I thought you would've been gone
I thought...
I really thought,
I thot,
I thought...
Okay, all right, okay, so this ain't so bad... I think
What I gotta do is I just gotta time the close cuz no matter what I think she's gonna see me...
Unless she doesn't, wait mayb- unless she-- whoa.
Unless she doesn't, unless I can time it so that she doesn't see me...
Baby: 𝘵𝘸𝘰... 𝘰𝘯𝘦...
Oh! Nope, she sees me no matter what
AHHH OHOH FUCK!
Holy shit, okay!
...Back here can you see me?
Baby: 𝘓𝘦𝘵’𝘴 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘩𝘰𝘸 𝘮𝘢𝘯𝘺 𝘱𝘪𝘦𝘤𝘦𝘴 𝘐 𝘤𝘢𝘯 𝘤𝘶𝘵 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘰
Oh shit oh shit oh shit
Okay well...
*static-y garbled noise intensifies*
Oh shit!
Oh shit! Okay, that's...
that's an option...
Baby: 𝘋𝘪𝘥 𝘐 𝘤𝘢𝘵𝘤𝘩 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘰𝘧𝘧 𝘨𝘶𝘢𝘳𝘥?
M: No!
What are you- what are you thinking?
Ohh don't do that, okay...
*static-y garbled noise intensifies*
*sigh of relief*
You see me?
You don't see me?
Oh shit! oh!
Okay alright that might've been a little bit early!
Baby: 𝘞𝘩𝘦𝘳𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘺𝘰𝘶?
Oh, I dunno!
You don't have... good object permanence
Oh fuck okay all right I can deal with this! I can deal with this.
Hi yes,
Baby: 𝘵𝘸𝘰... 𝘰𝘯𝘦...
I happen to be in the same closet that you lost me last time!
*whew* Alright...
…..
...BOO!!!!
Baby: 𝘞𝘢𝘯𝘵 𝘵𝘰 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘴𝘤𝘰𝘰𝘱𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘳𝘰𝘰𝘮?
M: No I don't not really
Baby: 𝘞𝘩𝘦𝘳𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘺𝘰𝘶?
I'm here! Hello!
Peekaboo-- this is a big game of peekaboo with a baby!
That's what it is it's peekaboo with a baby!
peekaboo~
You guys like playing peekaboo~?
I like playing peekaboo!
Baby: 𝘐 𝘨𝘶𝘦𝘴𝘴 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘧𝘰𝘳𝘨𝘰𝘵 𝘢𝘣𝘰𝘶𝘵 𝘮𝘦...
M: I GuEsS yOu FoRgOt AbOuT mE, HUH??
YOU BIG DUMB LOOOSER
Hey hi howya doin'
Whoa!
Alright...
Baby: 𝘋𝘪𝘥 𝘐 𝘤𝘢𝘵𝘤𝘩 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘰𝘧𝘧 𝘨𝘶𝘢𝘳𝘥?
Nah, you didn't.
I'm over here! Peekaboooo~! Peekaboooo!
It literally is... a game of peekaboo with a giant baby.
That's what this game mode is...
That's hilarious.
Baby: 𝘐 𝘨𝘶𝘦𝘴𝘴 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘧𝘰𝘳𝘨𝘰𝘵 𝘢𝘣𝘰𝘶𝘵 𝘮𝘦...
Nope! I didn't. Did you forget about
me?
Why do you have pins in your bodyyy?
You doin' acupuncture?
[Bells toll]
Oh shit oh shit wait wait
[kids cheering]
Did I win??
What the fuck? Oh-? G-goodbye!
*Laughing* What the frick!
What happened?
[kids cheering]
Well that's weird! Hey- "Butter For One"??
*gasp*
The single-serving butter stick?
I mean they're common, but they're still appreciated!
In these trying times a, a sweet succulent -- well not sweet -- a buttery succulent butter for one...
To die for!
[cRoNcH]
Divine~! Delectable!
Sure would!
hAhA
Ah!
That is funny! That is a really funny fact.
That is f-- Oh, Nighttime Fredbear okay
that don't seem good...
Okay but if it's the same format...
...Then I'm thinking it'll be okay.
Okay...  "Doors" "Teleport"... got it okay.
So, it- it should just be a matter of...
Oh this- oh god I can go to the closet now
okay,
Fine. Fine by me, all right let's see what's up.
Hey you here?
Alright am I gonna be looking for teeth or somethin'?
Whoa oh f- oh f-- oh fuck!
What the fuck?
What the fuck??
What?
Okay?
Wait, there's something over there...
Yeah there's something here okay so what is this about-
What the fuck
What the fuck- what do I do?
What do I do- what the fuck
wait oh shit hi umm okay you're there
so I hear him
I hear him tramps around
I'm sure that means something
Where is he?
okay so he's not there I hear him, where's he
going
Is he going over here?
No?
What the fuck-OH OH OH
(Mark screaming)
WOAH What the fuck
(more screaming)
OH fuck wait- wait- wait- wait- wait what do I
What the fuck, what the fuck
What the fuck- wait do I need to- does that I need to close the closet!?
what the fuck does that mean, wait
wait what the fuck does that mean
What the fuck- what the fuck does that mean
What the fuck does that mean
What the fuck- what the fuck
What the fuck- Does That Mean!
I remember this in Five Nights at Freddy's 4 but I don't remember-
What the things mean when they happen!
(whisper) oh fuck
what the- hello?
Comin' down this way?
Where'd ya go- what the-
HO OH FUCK (gibberish) FUCK!
(whisper) okay- alright
Where the fuck- holy shit
Oh my god!
Oh my god! X2
Umm... imma check in here
okay not in here
Where is he- left
Left X5
Okay I hear him-
(low voice)oh my god I hear him
(gasp) OO Fuck- I look away for one goddammed second!
(door creak)
I swear I look away, for one god damn second
No other one- other one
That sounds like the other one
Okay no- no
Oh fuck- GAAAHH EVERYTIME
Every fricken time
Im gonna check this closet cause I don't know what the fuck is up with this.
Or why
oh fuck
Oh fuck
oh shit. Oh SHit
oh fuck me.
oh fuck
*freddy laughing* ok
where is he?
Where's he gone?
still sounds here
wait, left. He's going left.
oh shit
fuck me.
[bell toll] Oh My gOd
oh my god
[ children cheering] why did I need the closet?
why did I need the closet?
why did I need the closet
why
Probably for the nightmare mode
*gibberish* ah, there we go. ah OH
Chica: Hey
Chica: You stop that, ugh god
Mark: I 'm sorry that was an accident
Mark: I'm- Chica: You're so clumsy. That's why my big sister doesn't like you
Mark: Well I don't like your big sister much either
Chica: OH How dare you?! I'll peek your eyes out.
Boink boink Mark: Ah my eyes!!
You here? All right cool I'm gonna go listen to that tape.
I'm sure it'll be fine
hello, Oh hi. Woah
I can see you in kinda detail now.
Ah, I bet that ain't good.
Are you Jeremy?
You Jeremy?
oh uh.
I'm thinking that wasn't ink.
I'm thinking. You know, I'm just suspecting
that might not have been ink
I'm thinking that might have been BloOoOOod
You, you know what I mean. It might have been bluuud
It might have been big old beefy blued
Ok so that is...
The last of the normal gameplay modes.
That's it. That's all of them.
So what happens now...
is, this shit.
there's only one of those.
oh no.
don't tell me they combine all of the characters at once cause that awful
oh, no.
Oh No
OH NO
OHHH NOOO
ok alright, well that
sucks
but yea. So that's what we have to look forward to.
but, you know what?
I don't have to look forward to that. That's a problem for future me.
that's a problem for the me that's not here right now.
that's a future me problem
and you know what's beautiful.
is that you can just push your problems off into the future indefinitely
because future you will always be there until you die.
and then when you die.
f- you don't have to worry about the problems anymore
see it's just logical sense so thank you everybody so much for watching.
I'll have more
Five Nights at Freddy's coming at you real soon.
Real hot and heavy but um
In the meantime thank you everybody so much for watching.
I don't know how long it will take me to beat these.
Maybe they're not like 20/20 mode hard
we're gonna find out so probably  tomorrow there will be another episode of this
ah, and we'll see what happens
so thank everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you in the next video. Buh Bye
outro Haunt by Shurk